and in the past few moments it's been
confirmed that a fifth person with the
virus has died in the UK around half an
hour ago Boris Johnson said that the UK
was making extensive preparations to
move to the next phase of its response
to the outbreak the delay phase and that
the current strategy is unlikely to work
on its own the Prime Minister was
speaking as it was confirmed that the
number of cases in the UK had risen by
46 to 319 coming up we'll be looking at
how a market continued their steep
plunge around the world and we'll be
live in Italy where in the past few
moments authorities have confirmed 1,800
new cases and 97 deaths in the last 24
hours but first let's speak to Sky's
Ashish Joshi about the news here in the
UK and Ashish let's start with that v
death being announced we've just had a
statement through from NHS England I'll
read it to you mark it says we can
confirm that sadly a patient in their
70s who was very unwell with a number of
significant and long-term health
conditions as pass rates and earlier
Hospital they had tested positive for
Kovan 19 our thoughts and condolences
remain with the patient's family and
loved ones at this difficult time this
is the second death that's been reported
today earlier this morning we had the
very sad news of a woman in her 70s
would pass away very similar case in her
seventies underlying health condition
complications and she was from the
Wolverhampton area so two deaths
reported on the same day this first time
that's happened since beginning of this
coronavirus outbreak
yeah and now what was the senior public
health officials saying earlier at this
press conference what was significant
about what they were so first Chris was
he was talking about the screening he's
the chief medical officer he was sort of
met the screening of all patients who
are in hospital with any sort of
respiratory infection or presenting with
respiratory conditions that is widening
out what is already happening they are
very very concerned about an under
reporting of cases because then all of
their modelling is skewed because they
have to know how many people actually
have Kove at 19 how many people are
presenting
with this infection so they can work out
the mortality rate see how far it's
spreading and see how many people are
actually infected with the the virus in
this country so now all patients in
hospitals not just people with serious
respiratory conditions with pneumonia or
similar conditions but this is anyone
who is in hospital being treated for a
respiratory condition will now be
screened for Kovac 19 okay
Ashish thanks very much indeed